In this video, we'll
build a CART model
to predict healthcare cost.
First, let's make sure the
packages rpart and rpart.plot
are loaded with the
library function.
You should have
already installed them
in the previous lecture on
predicting Supreme Court
decisions.
Now, let's build our CART model.
We'll call it ClaimsTree.
And we'll use the rpart
function to predict bucket2009,
using as independent variables:
age, arthritis, alzheimers,
cancer, copd, depression,
diabetes, heart.failure, ihd,
kidney, osteoporosis,
and stroke.
We'll also use bucket2008
and reimbursement2008.
The data set we'll use to
build our model is ClaimsTrain.
And then we'll add the
arguments, method = "class",
since we have a classification
problem here, and cp = 0.00005.
Note that even though we have
a multi-class classification
problem here, we build
our tree in the same way
as a binary
classification problem.
So go ahead and hit Enter.
The cp value we're
using here was
selected through
cross-validation
on the training set.
We won't perform the
cross-validation here,
because it takes a
significant amount of time
on a data set of this size.
Remember that we have
almost 275,000 observations
in our training set.
But keep in mind
that the R commands
needed for cross-validation
here are the same as those used
in the previous lecture on
predicting Supreme Court
decisions.
So now that our
model's done, let's
take a look at our tree
with the prp function.
It might take a while
to load, because we
have a huge tree here.
This makes sense
for a few reasons.
One is the large number of
observations in our training
set.
Another is that we have a
five-class classification
problem, so the
classification is
more complex than a binary
classification case,
like the one we saw in
the previous lecture.
The trees used by D2Hawkeye
were also very large CART trees.
While this hurts the
interpretability of the model,
it's still possible to describe
each of the buckets of the tree
according to the splits.
So now, let's make
predictions on the test set.
So go back to your R console,
and we'll call our predictions
PredictTest, where we'll use the
predict function for our model
ClaimsTree, and our
newdata is ClaimsTest.
And we want to
add type = "class"
to get class predictions.
And we can make our
classification matrix
on the test set to
compute the accuracy.
So we'll use the table function,
where the actual outcomes are
ClaimsTest$bucket2009, and our
predictions are PredictTest.
So to compute the
accuracy, we need
to add up the numbers
on the diagonal
and divide by the total number
of observations in our test
set.
So we have 114141 +
16102 + 118 + 201 + 0.
And we'll divide by the
number of rows in ClaimsTest.
So the accuracy of
our model is 0.713.
For the penalty error, we
can use our penalty matrix
like we did in the
previous video.
So scroll up to the
classification matrix command
and surround the table function
by the as.matrix function,
and then we'll multiply
by PenaltyMatrix.
So remember that this takes
each entry in our classification
matrix and multiplies it
by the corresponding number
in the penalty matrix.
So now we just
need to add up all
of the numbers in this matrix
by surrounding it by the sum
function and then dividing
by the total number
of observations in our test
set, or nrow(ClaimsTest).
So our penalty error is 0.758.
In the previous video, we
saw that our baseline method
had an accuracy of 68% and
a penalty error of 0.74.
So while we increased
the accuracy,
the penalty error also went up.
Why?
By default, rpart will try to
maximize the overall accuracy,
and every type of error is seen
as having a penalty of one.
Our CART model predicts
3, 4, and 5 so rarely
because there are very few
observations in these classes.
So we don't really
expect this model
to do better on the penalty
error than the baseline method.
So how can we fix this?
The rpart function
allows us to specify
a parameter called loss.
This is the penalty
matrix we want
to use when building our model.
So let's scroll back up to
where we built our CART model.
At the end of the
rpart function,
we'll add the argument params
= list(loss=PenaltyMatrix).
This is the name of the
penalty matrix we created.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
So while our model
is being built,
let's think about what
we expect to happen.
If the rpart function
knows that we'll
be giving a higher penalty
to some types of errors
over others, it might
choose different splits
when building the
model to minimize
the worst types of errors.
We'll probably get a
lower overall accuracy
with this new model.
But hopefully, the penalty
error will be much lower too.
So now that our model is done,
let's regenerate our test
set predictions by scrolling up
to where we created PredictTest
and hitting Enter, and then
recreating our classification
matrix by scrolling up
to the table function
and hitting Enter again.
Now let's add up the numbers
on the diagonal, 94310 + 18942
+ 4692 + 636 + 2, and
divide by the number of rows
in ClaimsTest.
And hit Enter.
So the accuracy of
this model is 0.647.
And we can scroll up and
compute the penalty error here
by going back to the sum
command and hitting Enter.
So the penalty error of
our new model is 0.642.
Our accuracy is now lower
than the baseline method,
but our penalty error
is also much lower.
Note that we have significantly
fewer independent variables
than D2Hawkeye had.
If we had the hundreds
of codes and risk factors
available to D2Hawkeye, we
would hopefully do even better.
In the next video, we'll discuss
the accuracy of the models
used by D2Hawkeye and how
analytics can provide an edge.